(violin music)
- We're an offsite facility
of the Natural History Museum
that's not open to the public.
This is the skull of a humpback whale.
Our collection of marine mammals
is the second largest
collection in North America.
This hole right here
is where the eye would have
been when it was still alive.
We have approximately 5,000 specimens,
and that includes dolphins,
whales, seals, sea lions.
I consider myself the current
steward of the collection.
I think of the term whale
warehouse as kind of endearing.
(chamber-style string music)
When people come to the warehouse,
definitely I think the first thing
that is noticed is the smell.
It has a musty museum smell,
but, because of the marine mammals
having a lot of oils and lipids,
there's definitely a smell of rancid oils.
We have jars filled with
various kinds of specimens.
Ah yeah, this is nice.
These are eyeballs.
Most people I've warned in advance
that, you know, this is what you need to
understand the place is like.
You know, it's not a tourist attraction.
The warehouse has several
different functions.
And one is to serve as a storage facility
for the oversized specimens.
But it's also the facility
where we actually prepare new specimens.
We're part of the National
Marine Mammal Stranding Network.
We respond to dead
stranded marine mammals.
And most of what we've
learned about these species
is a result of studying them closely.
We have specimens that have been around
for decades or even more.
The collection really is of
international significance.
If you're a marine mammal researcher,
you've probably been here.
Some of the recent
research includes things
like global climate processes
and how that has changed over time.
I'm a scientist, and
I'm a little bit removed
from the emotional aspect of things,
but I still appreciate the majesty
of these incredibly large,
charismatic animals.
And it's difficult to not
be affected emotionally
by the kinds of things
that we're studying,
animals that are on the
verge of extinction.
What are we gonna do about that?
(string music fades and ends)